avec nous maintenant jimmy jean
économiste en chef et stratège chez
desjardins bonsoir alors l'inflation qui
monte encore on se demande toujours si
on arrive un plateau est ce qu'on arrive
à ce plateau là où ça va encore monter
la
communauté des prévisionnistes qu'on
fait continuellement de moi c'est de
rajuster à la hausse de prolonger le
délai avant que l'inflation se modère ce
que ça et le succès une situation
complètement inédite on n'a jamais été
dans une situation où on revient d'une
pandémie encore des problèmes
logistiques il ya encore des pays qui
sont aux prises avec des problèmes de
pandémie il ya une pierre c'est très
difficile à prévoir ce genre
d'environnement là donc ça c'est une
partie de l'inflation qui est très dur
est atypique mais ce qui complique
encore plus la chose c'est qu'on a une
partie d'inflation qui est très typique
qui reliée au marché de l'emploi qui est
très serré tout chômage très faible et
salaires qui même s'ils suivent pas
encore l'inflation s'envoler les
intentions sont là les pressions sont là
et les intentions aussi les attentes
comment ça a augmenté de plus en plus
donc il ya tous ces facteurs mis
ensemble qui font en sorte que c'est
très difficile donc moi je dirais que
les risques sont encore pour beaucoup de
persistance et il va falloir que les
banques centrales prennent ça peut-être
même encore plus au sérieux que l'on
fait
d'accord est ce que les fai ukraine est
vraiment dans ce rapport aujourd'hui de
statistique canada sur l'inflation avec
l'alimentation particulièrement est ce
que c'est ça qui nous fera surtout je
pense que ça commence à paraître mais je
pense que le pire est probablement
encore à venir qu'on voit certains
indices des prix à l'importation et les
fortes augmentations donc c'est des
facteurs qui vont se refléter dans la
durée c'est des contres souvent qu'ils
sont décidés négocier longtemps à
l'avancé au niveau des inventaires donc
fort à parier que ça va prendre un
certain temps encore avant qu'on
ressente l'entièreté des effets mais
faut pas oublier qu'on avait des
problèmes de récoltes avec des enjeux de
météo qui faisait en sorte que on avait
déjà des pressions qu'ont l'ukraine a
commencé on avait déjà des pressions
importantes dans l'alimentation donc
effectivement les risques restent
orientés à la hausse et sa force les
consommateurs à faire des choix
peut-être moins aller au restaurant ou à
choisir un magazine un petit peu plus
est ce que vous diriez que il ya une
véritable perte du pouvoir d'achat pour
les ménages canadiens en ce moment
absolument et c'est aussi ce qui a
changé vraiment qu'on parlait au niveau
en 2020 2021 pendant la pandémie on
s'émerveillait du fait que le revenu
disponible est en hausse les banques à
augmenter quand on regarde ces variables
maintenant que l'on intègre l'effet de
l'inflation ça c'est beaucoup normalisé
on peut dire quand même par rapport à la
tendance prépandémique on est pas mal au
lac aux alentours des tendances mais
c'est beaucoup moins reluisant que ce
l'était ya quelques mois à peine étant
donné la vigueur de cette inflation le
dos oui il ya une érosion du pouvoir
d'achat mais c'est un mal nécessaire si
on veut ralentir l'inflation il faut
ralentir la demande pour ralentir les
ardeurs des consommateurs
il sait pas davantage un problème
d'offre avec les problèmes dans les
chaînes d'approvisionnement
c'est les deux cd 2 c'est ce qui rend la
chose compliquée donc on dit souvent les
banques centrales peuvent pas vraiment
avoir un impact sur les facteurs d'offre
c'est vrai mais ils ont le contrôle sur
les facteurs de demande sur l'immobilier
par exemple et dans l'immobilier c'est
en train de faire un certain effet la
hausse des taux est en train de calmer
le marché immobilier absolument
absolument le vus dans les chiffres
cette semaine avec une baisse de plus de
12% des ventes au niveau canadien on a
vu même les krills indices de prix aux
nouveaux canadiens baissé ce qui est
assez particulier c'est très précoce là
dans le cycle de ralentissement à
l'autre et effectivement d'habitude donc
ça prend un certain temps avec les prix
commencent à baisser locaux voient déjà
la faiblesse donc cesser aussi qu'il y
avait une exubérance donc en pompant
retraite mais l'effet des taux c'est
plus difficile de se qualifier pour une
hypothèque c'est plus dispendieux aussi
et c'est comme ça que la politique
monétaire fonctionne c'est en
ralentissant les composants qui sont
sensibles aux taux d'intérêt
l'immobilier en étant il ya les dépenses
en biens durables automobile tout ce qui
dépend aussi haut du marché de
l'habitation comme les achats
d'électroménager de tout cela va être
appelée à ralentir dans un environnement
le marché immobilier la banque du canada
envoie des signaux de hausse le 1er juin
de 50 points de base un demi point de
pourcentage et au mois de juillet d'un
demi point de pourcentage encore est ce
que ce sera suffisant
c'est ces questionnaires oui parce que
même avec ses 100 points de base
supplémentaires là on va être encore à
2% de taux nominal d'intérêt et quand on
regarde avec l'inflation mais ça va
encore dire que la politique monétaire
est un territoire très incommode donc
théoriquement se regardent et ce dès
maintenant plus purement théorique et
d'ailleurs il ya certains anciens
dirigeants de la réserve fédérale qui
sont en train de mettre la pression
parce qu'ils disent que les taux
devraient plus être aux alentours de 5
6% je pense que ça serait extrêmes et
c'est la raison pourquoi on est prudent
c'est parce qu'on sait pas exactement
qu'est ce qui est vraiment reliés au
site mais qu'est ce qui réunit choc
d'offre mais il reste qu'il ya quand
même une nécessité d'augmenter les taux
et si on s'en va là on se revoit aussi
en récession si on fait ça trop vite
effectivement ça va ça va être trop
déstabilisant donc mais il faut quand
même qu'à court terme il ya une d'une
séquence quand même assez musclée pour
au moins revenir vers la neutralité donc
ce à dire que la politique soit plus
accommodantes comme il l'est en ce
moment après ça effectivement il va
falloir prendre le pouls regardez le
marché immobilier ont levé en 2019 à le
marché immobilier ont le sida en 2009 75
sur les taux directeurs marché
immobilier avait ralenti donc on risque
ont raison vaut voir la même chose cette
fois-ci mais si seul exercice très
difficile pour les banques centrales
c'est d'exécuter cette normalisation là
en évitant de trop déstabiliser
l'économie tout en ralentissant en
ralentissant l'inflation ça va être
extrêmement discret merci beaucoup de
juniors pour cette analyse ce soit merci
à eux pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh
[Musique]